[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar torch infections screening
versus diagnosis
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott
to learn more visit
corelaboratory.abbott.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr claudio gali md phd associate medical
director infectious diseases core
diagnostic at abbott
dr gali you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody thank you for joining
today we are discussing today's serology
serological testing for screening and
diagnosis with a focus on congenital
infection
first of all disclaimer of course i'm
speaking on behalf of abbott and working
for abbott and now let's start with some
definition
when we deal with screening and
diagnosis actually those are a different
ballgame so you see the features here
the purpose of doing that the target
population test method the threshold the
positive result evaluation and the cost
so when we are dealing on screening
we are pretending or hoping to detect
potential disease indicators in
individuals that are mostly or all
asymptomatic potentially at risk
the method which should be simple
acceptable and of course to the people
and the stuff that will perform testing
the positive result
threshold
is set in a way to maximize sensitivity
because we cannot afford to miss
potential disease
and the positive result brings a
suspicion of disease and needs
confirmation
ideally a screening cost should be cheap
the benefits should balance costs due to
a high number of individuals to be
screened
whereas when we go to the diagnostic
side in that case we need to establish
to diagnose the presence or absence of
any given disease so population will be
mostly symptomatic or
should have been positive by the
screening and then needs confirmation
the test method may also be invasive and
complex because this is justified by the
need to diagnose and the main
characteristic should be specificity so
having true negatives and there is a
more much major weight on accuracy
the positive results should confirm a
suspect diagnosis always in association
with clinical data so no assay will
provide the diagnosis by itself and it
could also be more expensive and this is
again justifiable by the need to
establish a
now
let's take a few questions during this
webinar i hope this will be appreciated
by you
first of all when you have laboratory
asses available for screening and
diagnosis are those different according
to the purpose of testing others the
same ones with diagnostic thresholds
that are adapted according to the
clinical need or are the same ones
mostly the same ones and what makes a
difference is the combination and
sequence of assets to be used and
interpretation
and the right answer is the last one
very often if not everyone every time we
have the same assets available
and i would say
that what makes a difference is really
the combination and secrets and results
of the assays and how you do interpret
the criteria you use to interpret those
let's start with a very common infection
which is the human situation infection
you know that acetomegalovirus is a
nervous virus
it affects a variety of cell
compartments from the ectodermal layer
and so it is also known as one of the
most common and persistent infections we
have as humankind
the very brief life cycle is described
here we will not waste your time on that
the relevant thing is that
once the infection is established after
the acute productive phase is this
chronic latency phase
that
never ends so it's for a lifetime and
during the course of a lifetime there
will be several chances for the
infection to reactivate
as i said this is a very common
infection so you see here some data on
prevalence that not all countries do
report prevalence so no data are very
frequent but you may also see that in
the majority of countries the prevalence
of cmd infection ranges between 60 and
more than 90 percent so i would say that
in an adult population the vast majority
of people already are infected and these
of course bring some consequences on the
testing results and the interpretation
of the testing results
when you are dealing with cmv testing
during pregnancy
you have to consider that that period is
all prone to infection we don't know
beforehand most most instances
i'm sorry if the person has been
infected before or not
so we do have the likelihood to screen
and usually many people will try and do
screening to refer during the first
trimester of pregnancy and in that case
you may find
either an infectious syndrome with
symptoms or more often than not just the
serology that is suggested on a cmv
infection the imaging may be valid but
only in the later phases of pregnancy as
you see as you see here and what is
worrisome is that in most instances
screening is yet not performed and in
case an infection appears
then the consequences during childhood
will appear
let's try and define it a little bit a
little bit better so what happens is
that there are two major
possibilities the first one which is the
rarest is that during pregnancy a
primary infection occurs in this case
the transmission rate is very high
whereas if
the pregnant woman has been already
infected before which is quite likely by
the way being usually an adult then the
reinfection or reactivation may lead to
transmission
in a percentage of ranges between 0.5
and 1 it is not really certain because
you don't have so many data about that
so
regardless of the status of the mother
the majority of newborns will be
asymptomatic at birth
those that are symptomatic that 10 15
percent will have sequila in 90 of cases
so this is the high risk we should try
to prevent whereas in case of a
symptomatic infection unfortunately you
still have the development of sequila
but this is much rarer so it ranges
between five and ten percent and you see
here which are the most common disorders
and the sensorineural hearing loss is
usually the most common
we should remember that cmv infection
after down syndrome is the most common
cause of congenital disease in the world
so this is something we should really
look very careful at and try and prevent
as much as possible
now what happens during the course of a
cmv infection what do we use well this
is exactly the case in which exactly the
same assays are used both for screening
and for diagnosis and the flow that the
appearance of the different biomarkers
is depicted here this is of course a
generic scheme not so precise but to
give you an idea
during a primary infection you have an
initial positivity for agm
so almost immediately by the
detectability of igg specific to cmb and
the ability of antibodies
towards cnb is raising during the first
weeks or couple of months after the
infection
point is that when there is a
reactivation
cmv igg will already be there the
ability should be high and the igm could
be detected and usually are detected
again
so as you see here there is quite an
inconvenience in the sense that ign
testing alone cannot predict really if
the infection is a first infection a
primary infection or a reactivation but
the point is that the igm testing we use
should be as sensitive as possible and
this is an example of why
this is quite an old paper i would say
in which pregnant women were tested by
different assays for igm to cmb and the
other assays that have been done in
these cases are the igg ability and the
shell vial testing for cmv shedding in
the urines which of course is an
indication of the reactivation of the
infection and then the likelihood to
transmit again
as you see here there are cases in which
one essay may be positive and the other
ones are not and unfortunately in some
of those cases you do see a low ability
and you may see cmv shedding so in case
the test comes up negative in those
cases you are missing
infections that are indeed able to be
transmitted to the feeders so this is
the reason to have an ign testing that
is as much sensitive as possible
but on the other hand
think about that
if you are looking for a screening in a
high prevalence setting as most
countries especially in the western
central hemisphere will be which will be
the positive predictive value of a cmv
ign test would it be very high that is
igm positivity almost always link it to
acute or recent infection would be
fairly high
or would it be low as almost all people
have a chronic infection and ign
positivity is mostly linked to
reactivation and the right answer is the
third one again
and we have data on that that are pretty
i would say
interesting to look at
this is an observational testing carried
out in canada
last year published last year
without focusing on all the
flow here just look here on the right
when cmv available igg ability has been
performed on samples that were positive
for igg and igm that were 113
well only four of those at the low
ability that is only four of those
samples were taken from pregnant women
with an acute primary infection all the
other ones
where
all the infections chronic infections
that did reactivate during pregnancy and
the rate of reactivation during
pregnancy is fairly high may reach out
20 percent
during the wool course of pregnancy so
of course this is again
a very good reason practical reason to
limit do not to limit sorry testing
through igm and igg but to carry on igg
ability
and this is the schematic flow if you
wish on how screening
should be done or is currently done
during pregnancy so you start with both
igg and igm if both negative
there is still a counseling to be done
in order to avoid behaviors that may
lead to a primary infection during
pregnancy so counseling is very
appropriate in this case
if during that period you have a
circumversion that in that case without
any need of further testing this is a
primary infection and the need for a
prenatal diagnosis is really huge
the other instance is that you may have
a positive serology either
for igg alone
or for igg and igm in rare cases igm
alone in that case
igg ability should be performed and
again if it's low as we have seen in the
example before
and the confirmation for each igm is
then done by disability testing then
there is a primary infection we refer to
that status
on the other cases if the ability is
high
this is a definitely a prior infection
so no further testing is recommended a
grain zone that may happen because all
cmv agg ability assets do have a gray
zone so neither positive nor negative
that in that instance they should be
counseling and retesting as soon as
possible within a couple of weeks to try
and sort out if the infections is recent
or not
then
the utility is depicted here if you wish
this is a repetition just to confirm you
start with the same exactly the same
generic picture of a positive igg and
igm in the first case patient one this
is a primary infection with the low
ability
in the second case which is much more
common you will have a high c igg
ability and this is a reactivation
point is that
even the best acids are not perfect so
this is where the clinical picture does
play a role this is not exactly the case
in pregnancy but if you look at special
groups such as in this instance immune
suppressed patients after
transplantation
you may find a low cmv igg ability also
on samples that are belonging to a
chronic infection and this is why
knowing which is the status of the
patient before performing testing is
absolutely relevant again no assay no
combination of assad will be absolutely
diagnostic per se we need to have the
clinical criteria as well and this is
something that the lab should request
especially in the case of dubious
results in every instance
another point is that if we look at the
most recent recommendations at least
from the cdc
you see this phrase here it is not
recommended that doctor repeal it has
pregnant reimbursement or cmd because
laboratory tests cannot predict which
developing babies will become infected
or have long-term health problems well
this first of all does not take in
account the results of cmv igg ability
that possibly is not so widespread
second point it assumes that once the
infection is diagnosed there is nothing
to do except fossil determination of
pregnancy which is not the best possible
outcome
and this remember is coming from a few
years ago what happened next is that
nowadays we do have evidences that
antiviral treatment during pregnancy is
available
it's safe and may prevent vertical
transmission of cmv you see here this
outstanding paper published on landsat 2
years ago you see which are the
differences the yield in term of
reduction of the transmission when you
use valacyclovir compared to placebo
this is still one of the cases in which
placebo was considered you know that in
many instances there are ethical
concerns about having this kind of
studies but the first instance when you
have to prove drug safety and drug
efficiency you do that you see how huge
the difference is and so this may lead
eventually to a change in the cdc
recommendation and for sure it will lead
to a change in cnv testing practice so
to conclude
you know by now we already know of
course but this is to clarify the issue
that we do have
a clear picture of cmv serology and we
can't foresee a need for new biomarkers
to be developed because the current
combination of igm igg and reflex
testing for igg ability in case of
positivity for igm and igg will
guarantee a good accuracy in the
diagnosis of discrimination or reasons
versus chronic infection so we are
coupling the screening first and the
diagnosis later
and since this screening is still
controversial but we now have the
availability of a treatment that for
force will lead to a wider consensus for
its implementation
and that was cmv but of course there is
not only cmv in this busy world so
let's take a look at a clinical case
common presentation
let's read together this is a 34 year
old male individual that since was weak
as fever
fearing godania rash swallows cervical
lymph nodes moderate enlarged and soft
spleen sweating fatigue
the anomalies reports frequent travels
high proximity with people the same age
or younger
the presumed diagnosis is an acute
infection infectious disease is likely
likely of our origin but the person was
tested for cmv
for
epstein-barr virus and fro toxo with
those results as you see here well cmv
agm negative so this is not an acute
infection
in this case for ebv you have even a igg
positive this is developed
many weeks after the acute infection so
this excludes
an acute ebv infection even if the agm
are positive same story as the cmv you
have the igm positivity it is prolonged
or your reactivation may appear again
and you have a positive result for toxo
igg and ign so you would presume okay
this may be
a primary acute tox infection
this may be
okay
but
of course pseudologically it makes sense
because even during an acute infection
by toxoplasma condy you have the
positive igg that then weighs down but
may last up to until one year
and will appear again during
reactivation same story as before
then after a short leg of time you have
the development of igg and then again
you have divided it that was not used in
that case because this was a different
field okay a different ballgame as we
said at the beginning so it could be
toxo serologically right
but the point is that
generally a primary infection by
toxoplasma condy is a symptomatic in
immune competent persons this is a 34
year old young male
it's symptomatic in 10 to 20 percent of
cases and commonly it has
lymphadenopathy which is dc in that case
fatigue no fever or very low temperature
compared to what we've seen before
chorioretinitis that was absent and the
clinical course is benign and
self-limited
so go back to the case we have seen
before
and just point out that in this case we
had fever foreign which is not typical
for toxo the rash
and the sweden and these frequent
travels like proximity so
the other tests that have been performed
in this case were for hiv and it came up
as positive so this is
an acute infection by human
immunodeficiency virus and this was the
final diagnosis again once again you
combine
the results that you obtained by
microbiology variety testing with the
clinical evidences and you end up with a
defined diagnosis
i hope this is something that is pretty
much clear and i'm sure that quite a few
people here have seen such a picture at
least sometimes but let's go back to
toxo well toxoplasmosis is mainly
transmitted not by cats as okay this is
a possible factor but not so frequent
usually they undergo the raw meat or
contaminated water fruits and vegetables
but there is also the risk for a
intrauterine transmission and this is
why we are dealing with that in the
section devoted to congenital infections
and congenital infection
that results from an acute prior
infection not from a chronic infection
has a different degree of severity
according to when it occurs in cmv
infection it is definitely worse to have
the infection early during pregnancy so
the earlier the worst in this case
the incidence and severity increase by
trimester so it's highest in the third
trimester
and it may be again symptomatic or
asymptomatic as we have seen before
this is the classic triad of the
congenital toxo
idiosyphiloscoridinitis and intracranial
calcification you may have also other
consequences but the good news here is
that the treatment
is established since years so there is a
definite chance to treat
mothers
future mothers that are infected during
pregnancy in order to reduce the
incidence of congenital infection and
insecurity
just to mention
this is a classical paper on top so i do
outstanding authors here and this is the
approach for treatment in women that are
suspect or confirmed to have acquired
tons of cosmosity during gestation
according to the weeks there are two
different kinds of treatment recommended
those are safe have a good efficiency
there is also the likelihood or the
possibility to switch from one treatment
to the other if the first one is not
affected of course you need to monitor
the fetus during the treatment and
eventually also to carry on further
diagnosis at birth so this is completely
different from cmv there is an
established path since years and nobody
is questioning about the need to screen
for toxo during pregnancy
and serology for toxo is apparently easy
if you wish the same combination igg igm
but we have to deal with something that
is not so easy to interpret it is mainly
related to the igg detection
a very recent statement from french
authors and france is very advanced in
the diagnosis and screening and
diagnosis for this infection
stated that the first line criteria for
igg will should need a maximum
specificity alone
along with detection sensitivity for low
or equilibrium titers in both chronic
and recent
toxoplasmosis cases so this is one of
the cases in which we want to have
everything
good sensitivity maximum specificity we
may achieve that most classes are very
good just to make an example this is a
comparison by the same authors in which
you see that actually in terms of
sensitivity all assets considered are
good or very good and even better as far
as specificity is concerned so
apparently we don't have an issue do we
the point is that when you start
confronting the assays
there are quite a few inconveniences
same paper brings out those examples so
the nine toxoid assays that have been
compared were confronted with samples
with a range of igg levels that are low
medium medium high or high and you see
that the absolute values generated by
the different assets are completely
different
so when you deal with low values the
ones that were
pinpointed two slides ago
which values are we talking about low
values by which method and this is the
issue we don't have a real balance a
real concordance in quantitative levels
across toxo igg
and this is a couple of examples from
another study you see that the same
assay on the x axis is from diastole two
different assets from other uh
manufacturers show
a an overall correlation which brings up
nothing because of course since the
acids are detecting the same analyte
they correlate
but the point is that the results are
completely different
underestimated
in this case overestimated in that case
why is this happening
well
this is the general problem of
quantitation for antibody assays
actually we do not count antibodies we
are measuring antibody affinity and
ability
and potentially also different classes
so it is not unexpected that assays will
display
sometimes the local relation but very
often slopes that are completely outside
of a decent range
and the literature indicates a
significant concentration differences as
we're seeing between methods
which are the reasons here several first
of all which antigens are used to detect
antibiotics then the essay format direct
indirect then the technology that will
bring a different dynamic range and last
but not least the standardization you
would say okay we do have a toxo
standard
point is that we had several toxo
standards over the year
and as you see here
the different assets that are employed
these are four out of the nine we have
seen before
do have a different interpretation
different antigens different whoa
standard
you see that the the three of them are
depicted here this is the newest
this is the the oldest this is the
so-called third standard which by the
way was quite a mess because it was made
of a pool
having together igg and ign
and quite
logically
the range is different and the
interpretation of results is different
completely different
so
what you may do or what has been done in
several experiments is just try and
normalize the igg results
by recalibrating towards the last the
most recent international preparation
which is the first toxin and is purely
igg so there is no confusion having igg
and igm together as we have seen in the
former standard
this is what would happen you see that
that assay that has been already
calibrated towards the newest standard
stays the same
with very good coefficient of variation
those assays that initially did bring
much higher results because the
standards and the technology and the
antigens were different are down to a
level that is indeed acceptable you see
that the differences here are very small
unfortunately in clinical practice we
cannot read standardized assays so we
have to keep
using the same assay over time this is
definitely a field in which first of all
you cannot afford to change assets
during monitoring if you have to monitor
and second you cannot pretend to convert
results from one answer to another one
there is no correction factor
this applies to every antibody
quantitative antibody assay is
especially true for toxo
and
even in this case going back to the
simplest thing which should be the igm
reactivity we have the same issue about
productivity we did encounter with cmb
the difference here is that
toxoplasmosis is not so prevalent as an
infection as cmv is
so
the predictive value is higher but it is
not a hundred percent this is a real
life observation for my country from
italy they took three years of routine
this
in dark blue is the incidence okay so uh
which was the actual incidence of toxo
infection in the screening population
and this is the predictive value for an
acute infection of the igm reactivity so
best case it was 86
worst cases barely about 50 percent so
once again you cannot rely just on ign
positivity to diagnose a risk or exclude
a recent infection and we should
remember the or exclude
why
because in this case
what happens is that
the vddt testing will allow
to exclude but not to include a recent
infection well first of all
another set of questions the ability
testing results are those different
according to the essay used are usually
in agreement on diagnosis of a recent
infection and not so much in agreement
on excluding a recent infection
do not allow to diagnose a recent
infection are usually consistent on the
purpose of excluding a recent infection
but without a hundred percent agreement
one again anticipated that
the assets
cannot
diagnose a recent infection the assays
may exclude a recent infection which is
completely different
and this is how they should be used and
even the best assays here are not a
hundred percent accurate of course
unfortunately neither there is a hundred
percent agreement but definitely there
is a much better agreement for toxo agg
ability across essay than we do have for
cnb for the very simple reason that for
toxo first of all there is a
way more experience about testing and
second we are using the assays just to
exclude a recent infection which is good
by the way this is just to show a
comparison across two assays
we are not interested really in the
correlation we do see that indeed
uh the samples are classified
according to a threshold of four months
before or after
again we cannot diagnose the reason but
we can exclude the recent which is what
happens with all those dots here and the
accuracy is fairly good
and this is a detail about one of the
assets here that by chance is the above
assay you see what i mean here
when you have a high ability
none of the sample assay had been taken
in the first four months after infection
which is absolutely fine because the
risk once again the risk for fetal
newborn disease is highest when
infection is transmitted during the
third trimester so if you have the
ability to exclude what happened and may
say that infection is there but it
occurred more than four months ago this
is safe enough and this is good enough
there are efforts to try and have toxo
igg ability also able to diagnose a
recent infection but there are quite a
few inconveniences i will not detail
about just to mention one
in case the infection is treated early
after after onset which is something
that is absolutely possible during
pregnancies as we have seen
then the pseudological response will not
develop the same way as in untreated
cases and the maturation of ability will
be delayed so you may have a low ability
even an infection that are have occurred
a lot of time before of course you would
say you know that you have been
administering treatment but what if the
person changes monitoring or changes
places this could be a co-founder
we did forgot rubella didn't we
well indeed there is something to to say
about rebel as well this is again
completely different compared to cmv and
toxo because in the case of rubella we
do have vaccination we have vaccinations
since decades and the rate of
vaccination is quite high we still have
this residual risk of congenital rubella
and in this case the risk is the
opposite compared to what we have seen
with toxo so the risk of congenital
rubella
is inversely proportional to the period
of the station highest in the first
part of pregnancy and then much lower
after that
we don't have the large epidemics but
in some remote areas where there is a
large part of the population that maybe
is acceptable we still may have some
major epidemic and unfortunately even in
countries that have been vaccinating
against rubella since decades
the coverage may not be ideal and we do
have periodically small epidemics of
rubella during pregnancy which is really
unfortunate because no treatment is
there
so
when testing for rubella igg during
pregnancy this is something that is
routinely performed the options here are
you may change assays because the
positive threshold is the same across
method
or each answer is a different threshold
and a different dynamic range so essay
results cannot be transferred from one
method to the other
or low positive results should be
evaluated with care as there are
evidences questioning a protective
threshold
or finally
any positive results shall guarantee
immunity so no risk of transmission
well the right ones more than one
are those two
each assay has a different threshold but
most are around 10 units per ml but some
of those are not at that level but they
have a different dynamic range and the
results cannot be transferred from one
state to another this is exactly what
happened also for talks of jgg
and and this is the bad news if you wish
a low positive should be evaluated with
care
so
if we go to the classical
combination of results for rubella
testing in in pregnancy or in general if
you have a positive igg and the negative
igm the classical definition is this
person is immune so biovaccination or
natural infection no further testing
required
if igm and igg are negative this is
susceptible so
you should take care again counsel in
order to avoid getting infected during
pregnancy and repeat uh following a
suspect exposure if only igm are
positive this could be an acute or a
false positive you have to sort out by a
second sample if both are positive this
is either acute or false positive igm
and again you may resolve that but the
point is here because most in most
instances testing will yield the
positive igg
and there are questions about the
immunity about
on any individual that is positive for
igg and this is quite
a long explanation first of all
the standard well the standard has
changed over time
was it was based and it's still based
originally on emma gluten inhibition
titers
that were equal to 15 international
units and revised to 10 international
units 20 years ago
but first of all there is a grayson to
be considered
a gray zone could be relevant because no
assay is a hundred percent precise
absolutely no asset especially in
serology so having a clear cut threshold
will bring in conveniences in case of
results that are just above or below the
threshold and most of all and this is
very relevant there have been evidences
of reinfection in individuals with lgg
titers or levels
of more than 15 years we then the
assumption that results of 10 always
confer protection against the infection
or infection
and results below 10 indicates
susceptibility to infection is not
correct
and this is something to be considered
very carefully because when we have the
borderline results we should be very
careful to state that the person is
immune it would be much safer if testing
is performed that it should be even
before pregnancy to recommend a further
vaccine dose in order to avoid
serious inconveniences but not having
the person protected and once again as
for toxo the results obtained by
different testes are very different this
is an external quality scheme i guess
that most of you do participate in those
you see how different the results may be
without wasting your time any further
the reasons are exactly the same we have
seen before standardization
antigen not so much because it's always
a viral isaac but the purification
processes may be different the essay
format and the technology so we this is
a conundrum we cannot solve that by the
moment so even
if i says were used and standardized
against this preparation
the results will still be different and
we need to consider that and this route
the professor diemec which is really
very good at evaluating serology as many
of you should know
to assert that indeed it would be way
better to have qualitative assets for
rubella instead of quantitative because
quantitative results need to be linear
forcing the relativity of high negative
to close to those of the positive load
positive and as we've seen before
a low positive is not really indicated
or protection so this is something that
maybe would happen in the future having
quantitation not to such a high degree
because it's not really possible to have
a perfect agreement across essay but
cooperate industries manufacturers and
of course people that are taking care of
the
expert testing and bringing out the
standards in order to have a clear-cut
definition of rubella positivity that
could be applied to everybody
okay this is basically what i was
wishing uh wished to share with you
just before the end and just out of
curiosity it is a clinical case and
published that a good friend of mine
from bologna referred a few years ago
let's have a look together so
this is a liver transplant patient
treated with a hepatitis b immune
globally hyperimmune globulin is to
prevent hpv or infection
tested over time frequently after
transplantation as you see
you have
this
that is the igg
to cmb
this is going down
positive at the beginning going down and
then up again
five editing was very high at the
beginning
then abruptly became very low
and igm that was positive at the
negative sorry at the beginning
observation then tested positive
throughout the the world testing period
here
so what is this
well
believe it or not this is a primary cmv
infection
what about the igg and the humidity
that's simple in the preparation of
hyperimmune globulins
that were administered to prevent hbv or
infection there were also cmv igg
antibodies you remember that cmv is very
common so basically almost every adult
will have also cmv igg so those are
passive antibodies
and this is the active antibody response
to the primary infection
patent fortunate of course treatment was
started immediately in that case no
consequences but this is also something
that may happen
so if we wish to conclude
we may say that serology maintains a
high value on both screening and
diagnostics
but even a specific ign response will
not be sufficient to diagnose a primary
infection by gandhi or by toxoplasma
gondii or cmv
the standardization of igg response is
yet to be achieved
okay we cannot expect to transfer igg
quantitative results from an essay to
the other
there is a likelihood to harmonize the
results to bring those to a decent level
of agreement but not definitely to
convert and we have seen that the
combination of igm and igg results plus
igg ability allows for the best
diagnostic approach but i would like to
reinforce this concept
pseudological results theoretical
testing given by the most accurate assay
need to be evaluated in the specific
context remember what we have just seen
in diagnostic sectors especially in
those when you do have the clinical
picture the clinical history an amnestic
and clinical data are for sure of utmost
relevance
and that's it for today thank you that
will be very happy to hear your
questions now
[Music]
thank you dr gali for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is it possible to distinguish a cemv igm
response to a primary infection from the
igm response following reactivation
a good question thank you for asking
that
unfortunately not there have been
some studies in this sense that well
first of all the level of igm antibodies
is not predictive so usually you should
expect to have a higher level of cmv igm
in primary infection but it depends very
much on the time for testing so it may
overlap with the ones you will find in a
recurrent infection
there were also assays to use western
blotting for igm in order to distinguish
a response link it to an early infection
from a later one and this is still
debatable and for sure it is not
something that is used in routine so
unfortunately not and this is why it is
so relevant to run igg ability when you
have a positive cmd igm in pregnancy
when the diagnosis of a recent infection
is crucial
all right thank you
next question
which may be
the best interpretation in case of
discrepant results for rubella igg at
low levels such as
15 international units per ml by one
assay and negative by another assay
okay so the basic question is
false positive or false negative right
well it depends on the context
in pregnancy if you are trying to assess
an immune status towards the rubella
virus
it is safer if you wish to have this
sort of a higher threshold so assuming
that you have
this low result by any given assay
as we have seen this will not guarantee
protection because there have been cases
of infection or infection despite the
low levels so
on the safety standpoint it would be
better
to have a low reactive score that's
negative and propose a further dose of
vaccine instead or at least take the
precautions in order not to get infected
during pregnancy instead of labeling
that case as a protected person that is
not at risk of developing rubella so
this is my interpretation if you wish on
the clinical side
all right thank you
next question
are there differences in the cmv igg
avidity thresholds across the different
commercial assays and how do they
compare
yes there are differences um
all assays have a different way of
evaluating ability and the range of
response for a recent or a not recent
infection is not the same
if you wish from a
mathematical standpoint there is a good
correlation across assets but it is very
difficult to translate dividity result
from one asset to another one so this is
for sure of the of the cases in which
you wish to maintain testing by the same
essay throughout the course of
monitoring not because the assets are
not accurate in order to avoid confusion
especially on the side that the people
that will be receiving the answer which
is maybe the most complicated things to
to to do
thank you
next question
you said that quantitative assays for
toxo or rubella igg are not truly
comparable and a qualitative result may
be better is this process underway
already
yeah unfortunate as we have seen
if you wish
to have a real
correlation in the pure sense of word
across toxo or rubella igg results
you won't get that all these they will
correlate for sure again they're
measuring the same entity
but the results would not be
transferable
if there would be a chance or a decision
to
revert or to move to a qualitative
result that is positive negative it
could be better but there are a few
issues there to be sold first of all
there is still
the habit of looking at a toxic level
increase over time as a way to diagnose
so if you lose the quantitative aspect
this will not be available anymore
and this may bear uh some relevance in
reactivation
the other point is that
the actually the need that uh i
mentioned is more for rubella
and you know there have been quite a few
meetings on that i do remember at least
a couple of who meetings on rubella igg
standardization
that ended up with the general
conclusion that
all parties should agree among
themselves that is the w show itself if
you wish an isbc
the manufacturers in order to first of
all have the assets at least
standardized towards the same
preparation which is not yet the case
and second try and agree on a certain
level of positivity that could be deemed
as sufficient in order to guarantee that
the person is really immune
in that sense
i cannot tell anything specific about
the company and working for us
at the point
that we are here here we are considering
that likelihood but this is will not be
something that apple will deceive decide
the loan this is should be a joint
decision that will involve all
diagnostic companies and authorities
thank you
next question
is abbott considering to have a rubella
igg qualitative assay and not more
quantitative
but again this is what i just told
it is not about decision or another
company decision to do that
there is let's say a tendency to move in
that direction
if and when an agreement will be reached
in that sense i'm pretty much sure that
apple will follow the flow or
participate in the discussion and
endorse that likelihood
all right thank you
next question what is the place for
nucleic acid testing in diagnosis of
these infections
that's a will another bull game a third
one
yeah there is space for toxo and
especially for cmv if you are limiting
to the three infections we have dealt
with today cmv for sure
simply for sure especially especially
immune compromised people there is a
huge space and in that instance serology
will not add much we have seen at the
end that case of a transplant recipient
that acquired an acute cmv infection
when you have patients that are severely
immune compromised
there is either that the need of
preemptive treatment or the need in most
severe cases of severe immune
comprehension to start antiviral
treatment as soon as possible when you
do see an increase in cmv dna levels
that's for sure
for toxo
that's a little bit conflicting and by
the way
testing for toxodna is not so easy
because cmv there may be questions on
the best matrix to perform testing upon
and the period of doing that for sure
there is a space for that as i've told
in immune compromise and even during
pregnancy because there is a a direct
effect on the viral load in the mother
and the transmission to the feeder so
the answer is yes there is definitely a
place and quite a huge one
let's say that in this instance sorority
just sets the ground so the infection is
there and then the
relevant
activity on deflection should be for
sure uh a certain by nucleic acid
testing
all right thank you
next question
is there a clinical value of prodrome
versus post drone in early rubella
infections in pregnant population
that's interesting
yet i don't really have an answer for
that i have no direct experience in the
clinical barrier of proton versus
posture
you know rubella infection
the point is that
the
initial phase the clinical phase of
rubella infection is so vague and so
easy to be confounded with our acute
viral infection that actually the
clinical value of the protromic or
post-drumming status i would say it's at
least questionable
all right
thank you
and we will wrap up with that final
question
thank you dr gali
do you have any final comments for our
audience
i
guess possibly we have another question
also that could be ear of interest
i see that on the
i see that one now as well yes
there is a study from picone from 2019
showing very elegantly that low level of
rubella igg are protective
is that study not convincing enough you
mentioned that low levels should be
questioned can you comment please
i can only repeat what i said i know the
study this is quite elegant but it's not
conclusive in my view there are other
evidences for the contrary so
once again we are dealing with something
that is very slippery at least so
low levels by when i say maybe higher by
another essay be negative by third assay
once again we should all agree on which
is this low level that will guarantee
indeed protection and just for the sake
of it
every kind of result that we have
seen or we may see of course will bear a
level of uncertainty so we should be
very careful in assessing which is the
true
protective level for rebel igg if any
and we should then agree all on that
level and how to measure it
[Music]
all right
well thank you dr kelly do you have any
final comments for our audience
the final comment is thank you again so
much for having attended today i was
very pleased to be here with you and
very pleased to receive so many
meaningful questions and i'm looking
forward for the next opportunity of
meeting you all thank you
well thank you again dr gali for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you